you can't win the game is fixed so when
they say why do you burn down the
community why do you burn down your own
neighborhood it's not ours
we don't own anything
we don't own anything
there is trevor noah said it so
beautifully last night there's a social
contract that we all have that if you
steal or if i steal then the person who
is the authority comes in and they fix
the situation but the person who fixes
the situation is killing us
very powerful staff kimberly with us now
live from atlanta hi kimberly you're
very emotional at the time do you if you
take yourself back to that time do you
remember how you were feeling
the feeling that i had at that moment
was pure frustration and i was feeling
as if though the narrative was being
redirected and people were focusing on
things that had nothing to do with the
bottom line and the bottom line is that
we were facing injustices that were
severe and brutal and i wanted to make
sure that the narrative was put back on
the right track
and did people
respond to that
surprisingly people did respond to that
i i have
my first two books i have a co-author i
remember calling her the night that it
went viral and saying i think i may have
gotten us canceled i think i may have
ruined our careers but i feel like i did
the right thing and fortunately my good
friend gilly siegel said i stand by you
no matter what so i was so surprised um
the positive feedback that i got from it
and that for a lot of people it gave
them clarity in a way that they had
never had before
absolutely went viral didn't it the
video what did you want people to take
from it
you know the main thing that i'm always
trying to nurture in people is empathy i
think that's the greatest way that we
can move forward is that if we just
actually sit back and listen and
understand each other and i think
because it happened in the middle of a
global pandemic it was an opportunity
for people to listen and understand in a
way that they hadn't before because we
were all still and we didn't have the
busyness of our lives of getting kids to
soccer and picking up the groceries to
distract us from actually taking in the
things that were happening so people
were able to process it in a deeper way
i think
what's your message to those all around
the world but particularly in the uk i
suppose given that you're talking to us
this morning who feel marginalized in
society
i think the main thing that i want
people to understand is that we can you
know
we can assist in getting justice in
small doses um we think of it as such a
big problem that sometimes people feel
extremely overwhelmed and they feel
hopeless especially as they're dealing
with their their their government but i
think if we work on this one community
at a time just taking back our own
communities just fighting for justices
in our own communities we can actually
make a dent and make progress in this
fight
how do you think that people
will look back um at what happened to
george floyd
i think it will be remembered as a time
as a grand awakening and not just an
awakening here in the states but a
global awakening of people understanding
that you know um you know it's it's
funny here in america today is dr martin
luther king day today is this the day
that we celebrate his life and his
statement that he always made was that
riots were the language of the unheard
and i think that we recognize and people
will look back on it and recognize that
we need to hear each other before it
gets to a boiling point
okay
i'm not sure if you've got up early for
us has stayed up late but we really
appreciate it either way thank you very
much kimberly thank you 20 to 5 where
you are in the morning thanks a lot
thank you for having me